wieder der tag her teils chaotisch
begonnen heute denn wieder haben sich ja
selbst ernannte klimaretter auf der
straße festgeklebt und den berufsverkehr
damit lahmgelegt das passiert in vielen
städten diesmal wieder in berlin
hunderte pendler im stau die zu arbeiten
müssen aber auch rettungswagen kommen
nicht durch mit womöglich fatalen
konsequenzen
donnerstagmorgen 8 uhr berufsverkehr in
der hauptstadt während die berliner zur
arbeit fahren kleben sich radikale
klimaaktivisten dem protest organisation
letzte generation auf die straße schon
wieder ihre mission den globalen
klimakollaps aufhalten
zwei bis drei jahre zeit
18 jahren zwei karten behalten ist
eine eine milliarde menschen also
einbrachten der menschheit wird 7 um die
fersen
nur noch wenige jahre so die
klimaaktivisten hat die menschheit zeit
bis zur totalen katastrophe für die
weltenretter geht es jetzt nach eigener
einschätzung um leben und tod
berlin anfang der woche klimaaktivisten
kleben sich auch am dienstagmorgen auf
die straße halten den verkehr auf kein
auto kein bus kommt an den klima caron
vorbei auch ein spezial rettungswagen
hängt fest ein krankenwagen der
schlaganfall patienten ins krankenhaus
transportiert auch hier geht es
womöglich um leben und tod allerdings
genau in diesem moment und nicht erst in
drei jahren doch die klimaaktivisten
weichen nicht von der stelle stundenlang
harren sie aus es ist ein rennen gegen
die zeit und die politik für die
straßenblockade am donnerstagmorgen gibt
verbalen applaus die grüne
bezirksbürgermeisterin aus
berlin-kreuzberg clara herrmann steht
zur radikalen jugend
nicht nur in der grün regierten
hauptstadt kleben sich die aktivisten
der letzten generation auf die straßen
überall in deutschland kommt es zu
protesten in denen es minuten sogar
stundenlang für kein auto vorwärts geht
ob drews stuttgart oder münchen nichts
geht mehr die bürger sind genervt
[Musik]
für die klimaaktivisten kein problem
denn für sie zählt nur eins den
klimawandel aufhalten egal mit welchen
methoden egal wird dabei zum schaden
denn für sie sind diese maßnahmen keine
proteste sondern friedlicher ziviler
widerstand
was klimaaktivisten maya in diesem
moment in kauf nimmt sie und ihre
protestgruppe hindern einen
rettungswagen zum einsatz zu kommen
denn der steht wenige meter von ihr
entfernt
entstanden
manuel ostermann stellvertretender
bundesvorsitzender der deutschen
polizeigewerkschaft
der ostermann
ostermann es hat wirklich etwas absurdes
wenn man die bilder sieht die polizisten
stundenlang damit beschäftigt sind ganz
vorsichtig die hände von blockierern da
vom asphalt zu lösen mit dem pinsel und
sie dann auf rollbrettern
wegfahren wie fühlen sie sich dabei
also grundsätzlich muss man ja sagen
dass menschen für ihre eigenen
überzeugungen ein spiel ist ja
prinzipiell nicht schlecht ist aber wir
reden schon lange nicht mehr von zivilen
ungehorsam sondern wir reden hier von
radikalisierungsprozess von menschen die
ihre ideologischen überzeugung folgen
und die strafbare handlungen begehen und
ich sage immer wieder die polizei ist
auch die dauer einsatz wo sie anders
viel besser eingesetzt werden könnte und
politik möchte extremismus und
radikalisierung prozesse ausbremsen ja
bitte schön wird es endlich zeit zu
handeln denn was muss noch passieren als
dass das man leib und leben anderer
menschen gefährdet und anschläge auf
kritische infrastrukturen ankündigt dann
haben wir im beitrag auch gerade schon
gehört es geht ja um berechtigte motive
sozusagen eben menschen zu retten in der
zukunft aber wir haben auch gesehen da
steht ein rettungswagen im stau da
können menschen sterben ganz ganz
eindeutig im hier und jetzt auch wie
kann man das lösen diesen widerspruch
wer zunächst einmal gehört es dazu dass
die politik endlich reagiert ich bin
einigermaßen fassungslos darüber dass
politisch verantwortlichen sich noch
solidarisch zeigen oder bei der
protestaktion als solches noch mitmachen
die klimakrise ist allgegenwärtig das
mag zwar sein das rechtfertigt aber
nicht leib und nehmen unbeteiligter
dritter zu gefährden und hier brauchen
wir politisch konsequentes vorgehen und
natürlich eine polizei- und das machen
wir auch die verlässlich an der seite
steht und dann recht und gesetz auch am
ende des tages konsequent durchsetzt
aber es fängt an mit der politik und
hier wird weg ignoriert und terrorisiert
und da wiederhole ich mich gerne wir
wollen radikalisierungsprozess stoppen
wir wollen gegen extremismus vorgehen
hier haben gerade gerade und extremisten
am berg denn es ist wie es ist und es
ist definitiv kein ziviler ungehorsam
mehr sondern zum strafbaren um die
völlig unabsehbar sind manuell ostermann
stellvertretender bundesvorsitzender der
deutschen polizeigewerkschaft vielen
dank herr ostermann